what is up there what are you doing get
back in frame i'm giving you the
automation
we are here today to watch chucky
episode six
clear slash that like button and
subscribe click the notification bell
thank you all for showing the support up
hatred it means a hell of a lot thanks
andrew crying for this doubt
okay i think i think we're done thanks
for watching
hi
we're from the u.s census
we have a few minutes of your time so
how many members in the household just
the three of us
ages 39. that's not grown-up andy is it
becky why don't you go get some of your
friends from your room
this is everybody
mrs fluff wait
i forgot charlie oh go get him go get
him that sounds like chucky that sounds
a lot like chucky
hi i'm
charlie
wanna play
delayed response
you made me do this
oh
[Applause]
is that the girl from part two with him
or is that
cool she's going to show up later did
andy return to one of the movies yeah
yeah yeah okay all right he's been a few
of them yeah
definitely like a recent one i mean yeah
yeah oh yeah you're supposed to point
these out right away he's got chucky
like in a vault he's got his head in a
vault and he's like torturing him in
that movie
yeah besides you and me we went through
a lot as kids come on
yeah it is hurricane why didn't you tell
me you were keeping a living chucky head
locked in a sig
there it is
something i picked up in military school
i learned a lot from a p.o.w
the scream's the loudest of fire
those screams are my favorite
okay what aren't you telling me let's
just say that murder isn't the worst
thing chucky can do to you
that's
that's cool rachel fairchild you're
under arrest for the murders of megan
mcvay oliver hayden and detective sean
payton what
whoa
she didn't do it over your voice how do
you know she didn't do it i just do
i'll see you at
home
until you tell me son i'm arresting your
teacher and causing a [ __ ] storm at
school
andy barkley
who's andy barkley
he was his kid in the 80s whose
babysitter was murdered the whole
charles lee ray connection everything it
all comes back to andy barkley let's
talk to him my house after school come
as soon as you can what a coincidence he
just he just shot a chucky
you never weren't very good at packing
light oh very funny i don't see you
helping me
you want smaller pieces you can cut them
yourself
[Music]
that poor war woman
superior handling and just the quietest
purr from this pussycat
and i love the color
coronado red i like how she's always had
jennifer tilly's voice yeah
but don't worry we're gonna give you
another paint job too
i just love that color yeah it matches
your lip gloss
what's that
it's a hobby
origins and drive right over the body
i'm just glad you're not cheating on me
i'm sick
sick
it's cancer
we're gonna get through this together
ginger
come here
oh my boy
you ready look
somehow this is jake's fault
yep another beer
no i'm okay oh cutting back are you
chuckie
ah she's fighting
hello nika
long time
had to be
nika
i'm not nika why do you think i'm nika
i'm not
very good at lying chucky bluffs but he
doesn't chew on his fingernails
i stabbed you in the thigh ten minutes
ago you didn't feel a thing
i spent some time with you i spent some
time with chucky and i gotta say
i like you better
sometimes
when we're together i
i see you looking at me
and i know it's you
it's not jackie i live for those moments
i want to have those moments
all the time is so weird
i bought us a
[Music]
house bound two
[Laughter]
i'll watch that
i just feel like everything's falling
apart right now
you know
i'm always here for you hey lexi
he's on
facebook i just feel like you're
somewhere else these days
i'm sorry what
oh
it's like you said everything has just
been such a mess lately and i just want
to protect you no
it's over
[Music]
we're done
no junior please
please don't do this we can fix this
do you blame him no
not at all
jake wheeler
where are you
in a kitchen in hackensack
hackensack listen andy i have like a
million questions how do we find him
oh you don't have to find chucky
he'll find you
and if he can't find you he'll go after
your whole family to get to you we're on
our way
is andy gonna die in this show
oh no
gladys
[Music]
really did buy a house
my fiance grew up here actually right in
this very house oh
i so it was your fiancee's parents
[Laughter]
you've already started getting some mail
oh
i have an online shopping it shouldn't
okay okay
look how sweet you look
[Music]
goodbye sweet face
lipstick print
i feel like she
stan can she stand sure if he die
she's paralyzed oh that's right
[Laughter]
oh and then there's your juvenile record
maybe mcfay found out about your
delinquent pass
record how bad is her juvenile record
you're gonna need one
well she was a mass murderer yes i was
just like did you kill a bunch of people
what do you talk about in that
all the things we don't talk about at
home
oh
that's an answer don't we talk about
them at home
i don't know
you talk about me
all the time
do you know
you're my favorite topic of conversation
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
mean
the episode's called keep queer
oh is it yeah okay yeah i've made
another decision
i'm refusing treatment
i just want to live my life with my
family with whatever time that i have
left
that's true i could walk out of this
office right now and get hit by a bus
who knows what could happen you can stab
by a little doll and welcome whatever's
waiting around that corner with open
arms my god they are setting this up so
much
ain't nothing bad gonna happen today
oh you dick what is he gonna do oh my
god is he gonna he's gonna is that
strong enough to do that smoosh her
through and out the window
[Music]
oh
my god that poor junior
poor junior
that is unspeakably cruel
don't understand
she made it sound like everything was
fine wait no but clearly she got pushed
through the window yeah
that nail courage
i don't think your mother killed herself
oh go golly
he's gonna deck him
we were fine before you came along
told you it was his fault
okay for your song
[Applause]
how do you know if you really like
someone
when i first met your father i had
butterflies in my stomach whenever he
was around
i've never had butterflies is that how
you feel really see i don't know what
that feeling but if people describe it
oh my god sorry poor question
i was worried he wouldn't look at me the
same
this doesn't change anything
you're my son
and i'll always love you
okay
keep queer
i miss our movie nights
maybe next week we could do a double
feature
brokeback mountain
uh
you know just watch both versions
[Laughter]
[Music]
i think what some people are forgetting
is that that plan didn't work in that
movie it's going to work this time
especially with a two three foot
assailant
i talked to my mom
although i'm into someone
you
and this is all over maybe we could go
on a date
definitely
okay
he's gonna [ __ ] die
[Laughter]
just let me have this i have a feeling
it's gonna take a lot more than
goosebumps and pennywise to scare us
oh yeah
i think it's handy
it's probably andy
oh
i think it's chucky
let's wait and see
oh
oh lexie
maybe give lexi a heads up yeah text
give me a little text
it wouldn't cause you any harm
jake
oh no i got you now [ __ ]
but i'll let you go on one condition
all you gotta do
is kill jake
i do want to kill jacob
i know it don't watch this dude
can i watch
nice
get him holy [ __ ] guys move now move now
now
stomp on
devin are you here
mom
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no
so frustrating
this is the matricide episode
oh
[Music]
hurt all right
so
look
i really enjoyed this episode a lot i
did
there are things in it on the
there are
aspects
that genuinely frustrate me as a viewer
but i still really enjoy the episode
now here's what i'll say too
[Music]
i can i'll try to state some of the
things
that i feel like some people might say
to justify some things that i might
complain about
in here
because
the things that i have the most
complaints are in the last few minutes
but this is a 50-minute episode and for
like 99 of it i really enjoyed the hell
out of it a lot you know
so it's it's one of those things where i
don't want that one percent of gripe to
be the thing that
overshadows the entire experience
yeah yeah overtakes the whole narrative
um
but what do you think
no i i i think we're probably on a
similar page of like i
am continuing to really enjoy
a lot of the choices they're making and
whatnot and and uh the scenes that
they're allowing to play out and the
character beats they're willing to
explore whilst also having you know
your sadistic chucky story and tiffany
story running yeah alongside uh but yeah
i mean once you get to the end there is
a good amount of like
you guys got phones you could text
like gotta be some kind of contingency
for when you split up and you know the
whole point is like you're keeping watch
upstairs we're down here securing this
area we gotta have some kind of
communication i feel like you've all
encountered chucky
already yes this is not i get it when
it's like the shock factor but
especially you know like that all three
of them have have seen like devin has
the least amount of encounterment with
him but he's encountered him yeah he saw
him move in the hospital
and stuff
and they're just hit with this like
paralyzed fear of him
which
seems like a little weird to me and
contradictory especially towards the
point of when you know the with the the
pile of needles and all that stuff yeah
like go either get
so i could see maybe perhaps some people
might go to the comments and end up
saying
how like well you know the fact that he
actually ended up surviving when they
thought they killed them may have
shocked them even more into getting to
the state of fear i'm like nah they i i
can't agree with that assessment
due to the fact
that
they prepared for tonight
better than any other night
see because there's a lot in here that i
thought was great i think everything
they did with uh nika and jennifer tilly
who's
the character who's been taking over
jennifer tilly's body what's her [ __ ]
name tiffany tiffany yeah um tiffany
that i thought was so much better than
the last episode i liked it in the last
one but i thought it was way more
fleshed out i like the
sadistic
lesbian romance of this i call on a cape
cape queer where you have like the
bisexual relationship there especially
with tiffany because she's into chuckie
and
at her and nika and nika and then you
got of course devon and jake
i really i really enjoyed how all that
was going and especially that
relationship with nika and how she's
trying to outwit and how like that first
scene right away you're like uh anika is
doing a terrible job she could
immediately tell but it has this flip
we're like whoa i didn't actually expect
jennifer tilly or tiffany to be
kind of into her and actually on board
with this like i like that because like
no matter what he just can't win it's
better than being like beat up all the
time but it's you know but it's almost
further down a horrible rabbit hole you
have no idea how to escape then it
becomes like sexual abuse absolutely i
mean it already has been but yeah then
it just becomes that so it is it is a
sadistic i think jennifer tilly's
performance here was awesome oh she's
there like the brand of psychosis and
like bubbliness she is able to combine
is great yes
and again like because the series has
been so many you know shades and flavors
you know and some of her more focal
movies are
among the sillier uh entries into the
franchise like i love that they're able
to maintain that sort of
kookiness to her but also
temper it with the show's sense of
menace and
harshness yes you know like they're able
to ring really great tension and and
just like squirmy discomfort out of like
any of the scenes she's featured in do
you know the actor who plays andy yeah
i should
have been pulled up they're not
the greatest actors yeah andy and uh
kyle uh together but i love the
implementation of what they're doing
with them as like
chucky hunters yeah yeah yeah and it's
like it's it's a little cheesy but it's
cool it works but it's cool yeah for the
world yeah again it's well it's well
within the tone and yeah i mean if you
you go back and you watch like andy in
the cabin like you get how he's going
you know a little insane and off the
rails and i like that whole thing that
they have in the background about like
he's kind of a fugitive but they're on
this mission because they know no one
else is going to believe them so they're
doing what they gotta do um i i think
that aspect is awesome and uh i love i
love the inclusion of him in here and i
think it would be neat if they ended up
killing off andy in this series alone
because
speaking of like how do you bring him
some peace how there's all this trauma
with all these characters uh especially
when your main character here is still
in high school
going back to handy who is even younger
than jake of course this guy would be
like as [ __ ] up as he is and wouldn't
heal at all and no one won't believe him
so as they explore like cult of chucky
and stuff
so then dealing with that was awesome uh
i think
i finally this is the first episode i
mean he got dealt with a lot of heavy
hands to make me really care about him
it was to be genuine with you guys it
was the first time i really gave a [ __ ]
about junior and i really
felt terrible for him and they had
surprising gravitas towards a lot of the
scene work yeah with him and his mom and
uh bree like that scene in the car
oh what do you guys talk about the
things we don't talk about at home like
hamilton it's just heavy ash real
conversations right now yeah to have
and so that's why like the thing about
the things that frustrate me with this
episode is the fact of how i really feel
like the first four episodes in
particular
right uh rose above
or like elevated the franchise elevated
the material in a surprising nuance more
thought out direction
on all accounts yeah to to not just
emotional nuance which is that this show
has a way better grip on even in this
episode alone has a way better grip on
handling that in the in uh in the entire
chucky franchise like character
development and such
but just logic
around situations you know when it comes
to chucky
and i think they've and we started
saying this with the last episode that
they it's been
especially the reintroduction of uh
tiffany that it's going back more into
like like the campy terrain yeah so when
you have an episode like this i suddenly
feel like some of those moments where i
got frustrated with the characters i'm
like i feel like in earlier episodes
these would have they would have maybe
landed in the same position where chucky
got away
but it wouldn't be in the matter of of
me being like why the [ __ ] are you guys
doing something
yeah yeah why don't you rush down the
hall and stop at least
i mean even she the fact that like the
second
chucky gets in there like
like they can beat chucky they they
can't he's a doll with a knife
and he's got two of them one's got the
uh uh the the poker the poker and then
he's cutting a baseball bat close the
door
[ __ ] out here yeah you know office space
and uh like devin getting so hung up on
the whole
you know like he shocked him like come
on worried like just go up and kick him
stop on him
stomp on him and get everybody else in
the room so that we can all join in like
they're so insanely paralyzed by fear
and then it led in the outcome of the
mom dying so it comes frustrating and
then
i think it's kind of weird to me how the
whole thing with the cart going through
the window with brie
does not even seem to be brought up yeah
with all the mail that's like strewn out
in all of the parking lot and just like
i don't know anybody investigating that
would have to be like
this was involved and she couldn't have
created that momentum herself that's my
point is that they have an investigation
quality too here yeah that's really well
thought out
and
that's a part of this show that i've
been respecting is how much they
actually go into the detective work here
and then to completely not even talk
about maybe they talk about the next
episode but to not even talk about that
yeah it's like it makes a lot of sense
to go with like the oh it looks like a
suicide like that's perfect that's what
chucky would use to torture everybody
and to cover up what actually happened
but yeah that element seemed to be
vastly overlooked and especially with as
much tension as they've gotten out of uh
uh you know the the the detective
devin's mom you know uh
her being on the tail of everybody you
know and always you know sort of
suspecting what chucky wants her to
suspect of people i'm surprised that
nothing
at all got addressed of that yeah i
gotta understand i'm telling him within
the context of this of this show yeah
because i totally think
these complaints would not be applicable
in certain chucky movies sure you know
what i mean you'd just be like they're
dumb characters it's silly it's a goofy
tone whatever you know yeah and of
course there's a heightened surrealness
and and and heron cartoonish thing to it
but they've also established a very
clear a very clear world here yeah yeah
and and characters who actually think
yeah and
and then they have moments like the
nuance parts that we were talking about
or when brees confessed into junior and
logan like having all that mixed in or
devin talking with his mom about how
he's into jake and then like i love you
no matter like these are richly written
moments
then to do things that
it's harder to just give it a pass in
this show
just be going because you i could see
people just being like it's the chucky
franchise i'm like but i'm not this is
different yeah it's like they've done
such a great job up into this point of
transcending
obvious plot mechanics yeah to where now
it feels like a couple punches maybe got
pulled or a couple very yeah like if we
are to expect these characters to be as
sharp and logical as they've been up
until this point it seems now weird it
stands out that these things wouldn't
get addressed yeah yeah um because
they've just established a you know a
qualitative consistency because that's
what's strange to me about it is i
i was liking all of it watching the cape
fear thing being influenced by it
getting the idea that's a very child
like thing to do yeah
and
then they're setting it up throughout
the home i love the scene with devin and
jake on the stairs talking about going
on a date
and uh the the tension the mood i didn't
think about the fire uh him coming down
the chimney
that was all like really tension phil
yeah so touch tension
and i was even giving it a pass that he
did in tech that they weren't even like
we should give alexia a heads up yeah i
was even giving that a pass because i'm
like maybe they're probably just so
caught up in the suspense at the moment
that they didn't even they're not even
thinking about that right now yeah they
don't want to take their eyes off their
surroundings yeah so you can give that a
pass um
and it was just like the f the way that
executed played out by the time it got
to the moment with
her encountering chucky yeah you know
like you put up a fight with this
[ __ ] doll
man absolutely yeah you've been on the
hunt for that i mean like you've had
episodes where you've gotta hunt to
fight him when she was freaking with uh
like what because he has a knife
yeah that's like you guys are clearly
ready to attack and you've been ready
and you've had conflicts yeah so why why
now aren't you being as proactive about
it as it seems like you've wanted to be
this entire time yeah yeah it's not me
it's not made clear
uh at all i don't think it's made clear
i feel like a lot of what people might
say would be a
filling in the blank for something the
show itself hasn't actually presented
yeah yeah in even a visual storytelling
language maybe he felt this way i don't
know all three of them just get kind of
dumb to me in that moment you know yeah
yeah i i i locked the door and beat his
ass yeah yeah
especially too when he gets him on the
ground like that moment of him being
dazed like they gave it it wasn't so bad
as like
their moments in halloween kills where
people do just stand and allow michael
to come and kill them yeah or it's not
that but like yeah the whole thing with
the taser i'm like dude no you've got an
opportunity kick the knife away step on
his face and if you go and start
stomping on him they're gonna probably
hurry in too yeah so
yeah i mean you know it ultimately sets
up that greater thing of like why didn't
he step and it's it's that too of like
they're clearly aware of certain things
that they leave dangling like that like
he runs by devin and evan's like i don't
know you'd even try to touch me because
obviously he's got the plan to you know
frame them for the death of devin's mom
or something but but yeah like it does
kind of
when it's not being as smart
it calls attention to itself yeah which
is unfortunate because it sucks that
like that little bit seems to overshadow
a lot because it's the final moment no
it's the ending note so it leaves me
with the ending note when i was like man
i'm really digging this episode and i
and like i said episode 5 was like my
least favorite and i over all like this
episode more than episode five like
contextually speaking i think this is a
better episode than episode five
um
but man those that final moments was
like oh but it left me with that feeling
of that really uh
i left this
i got me like genuinely like frustrated
yeah yeah so like when she died
especially like goddamn this is [ __ ]
ridiculous yeah right
you can't you can't just have one
dangling chucky
you know you gotta you can't you can't
kill him now and leave nika's the only
one
man but
but yeah also i misspoke at the
beginning kyle is not it wasn't a
babysitter she was his foster sister
i should say
she and chucky two yeah child my child's
played too and andy goes to live at a
foster home and she's like right across
the hall or something and then they kind
of it's also a bit of all blurred me i
haven't seen all of them i've seen them
good i've seen enough of them and
they're all blur
yeah it's like i've seen them all over
the years and now it's like you know and
with like spiderman yesterday and
everything we kind of rocketed right
into this episode so i was like wait
okay let me get my child's play lexicon
back in my brain
yeah and i mean andy barkley like you
know he's he's you know
beardy kind of yeah i mean he doesn't
recognize him at first he's iconic but
if there are times when i'm like there's
a lot of guys who look like this guy so
i don't want to just point out the first
guy with a beard and be like andy yeah
it's like you have the hunch but yeah
yeah just wait for a confirmation and
i'm like like cult of chucky i saw like
pretty recently even but it was the same
thing of like i gotta i'm so used to
child auntie like my mind goes right to
there so i'm always like okay yeah yeah
that's him grown up
but yeah man i'm excited to see how they
expand on that and i hope that delivers
in some way shape or form for the two of
them even if they both die even if both
andy and kyle die by the end like i i
hope that amounts to something kind of
cool
that's my favorite like movie trope is
when they do
when when you have an established actor
as an adult
[Music]
and then they decide to cast like them
as a kid
they tend to try to make or younger they
try to make their haircut look like how
they did before yeah like kind of like
you know like let's say like a kitty boy
yeah let's make them look like them yeah
they are now but in kid size yeah
exactly most of the time though when
they do [ __ ] like this you're like they
look so much different than when they
were yeah
yeah god what's his his name's alex
something and i think her name is
christine elise or whatever
but guys i mean what'd you think do you
completely disagree with us
uh have we completely
lost your respect here you go i'm not
going to watch this show with you guys
if you guys don't get chucky yeah
anyway subscribe and hit that like
button click that notification bell last
but not least let's do a page
i want to shout out david gandy because
i don't think david gandy is ever going
to watch this show oh what a [ __ ] cause
david striker is the kind of guy who
watches it chucky branches the kind of
guy who's in the chucky movies no
not the kind of individual no yet here's
the thing david if you were to encounter
chucky
i feel like you would kick his ass yeah
i think you would easily whoop that
man's ass you'd be ready in a heartbeat
nothing surprises you man i've hung out
with you i've talked to you in person
sometimes
cold desires i i sometimes i'm like dude
you've been a supporter of us for so
long but i i don't even know if you like
us
so call it so unfazed you might be if
you were to encounter a living doll and
i think this makes such such a badass
guy right there
you wouldn't be like these characters no
first time encounter don't even have to
get past the initial shock
instantly
annihilate doll that's the gandy way you
know what you would say
you just got gandy dude you just got gan
you got your ass ganded to ya i mean i
think david gandy much of a sweetheart
as he is
performs at churches and such
i could also see a version where david
is a secret vigilante who likes to
torture his victims oh yeah he's got
dark side you could totally feel that
dark i mean that kind of sincerely
totally feel that dark side in there
yeah yeah yeah so i mean you know i'm
glad that we're in your good graces i
would i would hate to meet that side of
you david gandy
and he's a fan of photographer you can
manage he's got a bunch of polaroids oh
yeah it's just blow out david
he just did a 60s voyeur movie in that
room yeah you know and then sneaks in
and murders the big liquid yeah yeah
that comes back develops the pictures
hangs them up these are my heart
yeah that's david ford that's david
i will see you guys thanks david
[Music]